since the media and the politicians and
the people with socialistic tendencies
have become so ignorant that they don't
know what a millionaire is let's stop
and define that for you
a millionaire is not someone who makes a
million dollars a year a millionaire is
someone who has a net worth of 1 million
dollars or greater your net worth is
calculated by your assets minus your
liabilities what you own minus what you
owe if you own something worth a million
dollars and you own nine hundred
thousand dollars on it then your net
worth is not 1 million dollars it's 100
thousand dollars and you would not be a
millionaire so the purpose of this show
is not just to get you out of debt it's
to cause you to take the steps to build
wealth for the good of your family and
so that you can be outrageously generous
for that reason I've gotten sick and
tired of hearing liberals and left
wingers say it's impossible to win in
America today and so we need to start
giving you quote unquote free stuff from
the government which is a socialist idea
not a capitalist idea capitalism is not
perfect but it works better than
socialism and we have more millionaires
in America today than just about
anywhere else in the history of man and
almost all of them are first generation
rich they did not inherit the money what
does that mean well that means that 88%
of the people that qualify as a
millionaire started with nothing or
virtually nothing they did not inherit
the money so we decided you know okay
well millionaires are all crooks
well millionaires are all famous
entertainers or they're athletes or
they're actors or actresses or they're
the brilliant people they're the ones
with the 4.2 GPA and just none of that
is true now some of that is true but it
is not the norm a typical man
there's none of those things so we
decided a few years a year ago to start
doing a millionaire theme hour and
interviewing those of you that are
millionaires so that we can tell the
truth to other people and then if you're
not a millionaire listen and hear the
attributes of a millionaire and what
they did and how they did it and where
they are and what they invested in and
then copy them that's called studying
best practices we're gonna start today
with Gary in Houston Texas hey Gary how
are you hello Dave what a pleasure to
talk to you after all these years of
listening to you well thank you sir so
what is your net worth probably about
1.8 million right in there and what's it
invested in mutual funds I have a
company I've been working with for 25
years it keeps me invested very well and
teaches new management and etc etc that
is that's all what's invested in um I've
got stocks and bonds okay all right
yeah and how old are you I am 60 okay
how much of this did you inherit none
okay and so that means you started with
nothing and over the last 30 40 working
years you've done this so what's your
average income been over your working
lifetime
well my I was one of those ones that
started low and reached high and now I'm
at a plateau because I am working two
days a week now I would say my average
income each year was about a hundred and
fifty thousand okay what do you make now
way less than that I'm partially
disabled and I just work two days a week
I would say make about eighty thousand a
year okay very cool and what has been
your career I'm sorry what career field
were you in I am a general Dennis okay
Dennis Darin so your degree is in
dentistry
what would your GPA it undergraduates
about 3.7 and in dental school is about
3.2 somewhere right in there how much
I'm gonna get out of dental school area
how much of this wealth was caused by
you borrowing money to build wealth
that is a great question because I
always listen you as a debt-free
advocate which I am but in order to make
the money I had to borrow money because
I had none and I looked at that as an
investment so I borrowed a lot initially
to buy my practice and equip it okay so
am I considered oh I would say about a
hundred thousand okay so you want a
hundred grand in debt to buy your
practice and equipment and that's
resulted in really your income which
then resulted in your debt right that's
correct okay
all right yeah what part has that I
couldn't even do it do it yeah what part
has giving played in your financial plan
through these years
well everybody that knows me even before
I was you know wealthy to this degree
has always done that my whole career and
that's just kind of a passion for me
just to give back and that type of work
to people that need it okay so a lot of
pro bono work then okay lots of it Wow
what what is the most expensive pair of
blue jeans you ever bought 50 dollars
how many new cars have you bought since
you became are before you became a
millionaire probably three and two of
them were poor judgment okay well they
were because I didn't know you then and
now when I listen to you it's like what
was I thinking cool but I get it now
alright I really do I mean I heard you I
was driving into Houston and heard
people that had made it to call in and I
know how hard you try to help people I
listen to you all the time and I figured
maybe by calling somebody would hear me
and and get some help you know if you
would sir telling them it is it's very
inspirational 1.2 or 1.8 million dollar
net worth mainly in mutual funds now
okay so the 20 year old Gary is
listening to us right now or the 20 year
old Gary's wife is listening to us right
now
what do you tell them can it still be
done absolutely you know what it really
took it
it was not an overnight process but no
one knows that better than you it it
took making a decision and following
through as closely as I could to the
plan I had I had decided to follow and
there were I went off in the weeds for
sure but I was able to come back and
just take the plan and you know it
gradually just grew and grew and grew
it wasn't invent and you know the funny
part is is I was getting a lot of help
from mentors and friends I know you say
to if you want to be successful hanging
with successful people but when I first
read your book I had covered you know
three baby steps without even knowing
what I was doing
yes doing it but then when I got to the
debt snowball I mean when I read that I
still had debt but it could not believe
how quickly that paved the way to be in
debt free very cool Gary your great
American hero thank you for sharing the
story it's inspirational 1.8 million
dollar net worth average income through
his working life 150,000 he's saved and
invested all the time started with
nothing didn't inherit it typical
millionaire but they're not typical are
they this is the Dave Ramsey show hey
you guys Rachael Cruz here hope you're
enjoying the Dave Ramsey show and did
you know that I have my very own YouTube
channel yes that's right it's kind of
better than
I'm kidding I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you